speaking seminar
uh and we're extremely
happy and lucky to have udi shapiro
joining us today
and uh let me just give you a few words
about um
about the event
people
some people are in person and some
people are remotely on zoom including
myself right this moment and uh people
can simply raise their hands obviously
in the audience for questions those in
zoom can type the questions on the q a
at the bottom of the control panel
and udi will answer i guess as many as
possible
probably during the q a session after
his lecture
about our theory
of computing seminar series
well you're all in the simon's uh
institute you probably know it but just
to repeat uh we have been there since
2012 due to a generous uh gift from the
simons foundation
we are a place for collaborative
research bringing together computer
scientists and others to study theory of
computation and its connection to the
world
and uh i think that today's lecture is
an incredible example of the connection
of a theory of computation cryptography
actually
distributed computing and democracy
and uh our distinguished speaker today
is udi shapira who's a professor in
weissmann institute and i think he's
visiting columbia institute right now in
columbia university right now
he is a truly and this interdisciplinary
scientist entrepreneur artist and
political activist he's worked in
works that have made a giant impact on
biology on economics and on
sort of the our infrastructure he got
his ba from tel aviv in mathematics and
philosophy his bhd from yale
and he's been with the with the weizmann
institute ever since where he's the
harry wine web uh
professor your chair of computer science
and biology
and he's worked on logic programming
algorithmic debugging
um
biology um sort of coming up with a
biological computer
and today he's going to tell the tell us
about his views about uh i guess
blockchains foundation democracy
and uh his activities in the field
i think this has started since uh night
2017 his work in this field and he even
founded a new israeli political party
called democratic uh he's also a bass
singer and a founder of an artistic
director of bar rock band
and maybe he'll tell us about it in any
case i am really happy to welcome ud to
the simon's institute
and uh
go for it ud uh let's take the stage
thank you okay thank you shafi for for
this kind introduction uh it's
it's great to be here and thanks for the
invitation and it's great uh to give a
talk in person
to real people so there are real people
in the audience some of them i know and
love so that's uh that's great
and uh it's a special treat to the
people here if you have questions during
the talk
uh uh i'll try to answer them uh but
otherwise
we will uh we'll
try to answer questions at the end
so uh
the work is joint work with my
colleagues and students
uh nimrod almond gal shahaf uripoco
and several other colleagues which i
will mention during the talk
and
the first question that may come to mind
is you know why
why this doesn't work that's the first
question
okay
see
okay
this works
i know it's uh the computer doesn't
doesn't switch the slides for some
reason
itself
again
works okay so the first question is why
talk about this hype filled uh
futuristic uh concept of of a metaverse
in such a
respectable to such a respectable
audience
and my personal answer
is one of them is nostalgia
so i went uh
through the web and collected
uh 25 years old
screenshots
of my happy days in in the metaverse
uh from 1995 six and seven
and what you see here is a
two-dimensional metaverse
where these uh
are our avatars to the
icons of people who are in this webpage
visiting this webpage virtually and they
can talk and and chat
and uh
they can even tour the web together so
there is a notion of a tour bus here's a
tour bus driver and people can hop on
the bus
and tour the web together which which we
did
here is a bus with several people
on board
and uh
we had live events so here's an aol
hosted live event
here's the host here's the guest here
some of the audience
and uh excite hosted the
um this community at its peak it had
several tens of thousands of people
at a time some with a real identity some
kept their anonymous identity
and uh
you could play games uh
et cetera et cetera so these are the
happy days of
of metaverse 25 years ago and
this is actually the product of
what we see is a virtual places
1.0 2.0 which it was launched in 1995
same day is netscape
1.0 if people are old enough to remember
10 days 10 years before facebook
and it was done by your big company i
founded in 1993.
so that's the nostalgia part
but
a more
substantial uh
substantial reason to to talk about
the metaverse is i really think it's the
right
integrative concept for where we're
headed so
ignore whether it's 1d or 2d or 3d the
idea of
integrative
digital space that we will all we are
all inhabiting and will inhabit inhabit
um
more and more deeply in the future
metaverse is a good word for it
and
so let's try to define it at least for
the purpose of this talk
and i i opt for a very simple definition
it's just a network of digital
communities
you know it could be uh
as i said i don't care about the
dimensionality at this point just it's a
network of digital communities and
actually we already live
in a very rich metaverse
these are the
uh
social networks and
the first seven each has more than
billion
users or members
but we shouldn't forget other
digital communities the community of of
hosts and guests guests of airbnb
community of drivers and passengers of
uber community of buyers and sellers of
amazon marketplace
et cetera et cetera so we already live
in a rich
uh metaverse
which will only become
richer and and deeper and will spend
more and more time there
and really there are
three possible futures for our lives in
this digital
uh
digital lives in in the metaverse
one is democracy which we all know and
love and
can be characterized by by one person
one vote it's just part of the
characterization but it's an important
one
autocracy which maybe periodically can
be characterized by one person has all
votes
an example is meta amazon airbnb uber
and
plutocracy uh where people vote with
their money so one coin is one vote and
i think almost the entire crypto world
can be characterized as plutocratic and
i'll i'll get deeper into this
notion of plutocracy uh in the talk
so these are three possible futures uh
and as you've seen
i have examples for for autocracy and
plutocracy but i don't really
have good examples of of uh digital
democracy except perhaps proof of
personhood which is the beginning of a
direction in the crypto world
so uh
what what's why why don't i have good
examples because really the main part of
the metaverse today
is non-democratic and specifically if we
look at history and try to analyze what
we see today in a more historical
perspective it's really a feudal system
what we have today and what
characterized feudal system a federal
system is that we have a feudal lord
that has all
branches of government legislative
executive and judiciary and if you look
at the
especially in uh it's it's it's blatant
in social networks that
facebook decides both what are the rules
they execute the rules they judge by the
rules etc
so uh but but in all these
examples i've given these are all
autocracy's
feudal systems specifically in that
sense another aspect of the future
system is that members have no civil
rights
there's no due process you cannot truly
appeal or have have rights
uh of any sort and also
for the americans among us uh we are
keep being subject to taxation without
representation
our digital capital our personal
information is taking from us taken from
us and is being exploited without
remuneration
and we work we look at ads we create
content and we get
get no money for that so
a good cause for rebellion
uh so let's let's look at at slightly
greater depth at the powers that are
shaping the future of the of the
metaverse and there are really two
big classes uh uh powerful and and and
dominant classes one is the autocratic
one and the other is the plutocratic the
meta and the crypto metaverses
and here we have proprietary technology
trillion more than trillion dollars
behind it
hundreds of thousands of programmers
developing this for the different
companies
thousands of researchers or
in in the in all these big companies uh
together
and several billionaires were pushing
who are pushing this so that's one
direction with a lot of money and a lot
of power and including huge brain power
i'm not
there's a lot of brain power that
invested in in perfecting the autocratic
metaphors
and and of course zuckerberg you know uh
stated he will invest even more
explicitly in these autocratic metaphors
on the other side of the equation we
have a
plutocratic
team
the the crypto team
so the technology is not quite
proprietary but it's not free either
and you either need
either some of it is proprietary and in
general to participate you need the
capital a lot of capital so it's not
it's not open in that sense it's not
open to ordinary people
um
and there's again huge amount of uh
money and programmers and a huge amount
of research
that's going on behind
blockchain and cryptocurrencies uh today
probably there are thousands of patents
being processed as we speak in the
cryptocurrency
bitcoin a blockchain world
right now
and also a lot of rich people who want
to push this even further
so these are you know
so let's lump them together okay uh
and put both of them on the right so we
have lots of money lots of people lots
of brain power and what do we have
for democratic metaverse well
first of all uh
really any technology that should be
developed for that fundamentally has to
be a common good you know otherwise it's
self-defeating it will become yet
another
autocratic or plutocratic domain so if
you want it to be truly truly democratic
it has to be
common good which means it can be funded
or either by governments or by
by philanthropic organizations or
individuals
it cannot be for profit
but so that's the sort of the difficult
part the good part is that there are
really eight billion people around who
are going to benefit from it so if you
look on this side
those who will directly benefit will
become in better shape
uh you know
hundreds of thousands million two
million ten million people tops
you know will become richer and better
off if the non-democratic metaverse
dominates our lives but
on the left-hand side you know there are
eight billion people out there waiting
for for this to to better their lives
but presently there's no money and i'd
like to say you know i uh
i
not disrespecting the science that has
been done in this i mean lots of good
science has been done but if you compare
it to the brain power invested in
in clouds computing
in uh microsoft research google research
amazon facebook research
and cryptocurrencies research compared
to the amount of science that being done
behind democratic metaverse you can say
that there is
almost no science there
uh
at least quantitatively
so uh
maybe
rather than trying to do this impossible
and do science for democratic metaverse
without support without money maybe you
can
just work hard on a few people you know
the the board of facebook maybe
zuckerberg himself and his wife
convinced them that the right thing is
to turn facebook into a democracy and
this
this will solve our problem
so uh so can this be done
well uh unfortunately
okay what do i mean by that i mean that
make facebook members owned and governed
okay so give it to the public to them to
the members
and uh have members
remunerated for their digital capital
and for for their labor okay so that's
let's let's let's do that let's convince
a few people if we convince them
we're done right at least made a huge
step
well the answer is that even if you
convince them and they decide they
cannot
and the answer and the reason is that
the difficulty facing digital democracy
or democratic metaverse
is not the money and power of the
alternatives but it's the enemy from
within
and that's the fake
and duplicate identities so what
facebook does every quarter they delete
over a billion
fake and duplicate accounts every
quarter
so uh and sometimes more sometimes two
billion
so
we don't know how quickly they do it we
don't know how successful they are but
it's
it's reasonable to assume that at least
half the accounts in facebook are fake
or duplicate
and if facebook were to give power and
money to its members
uh you know they'll be hard-pressed
to keep uh you know to keep that percent
below 99
okay because there will be so much more
motivation to create fake duplicate
accounts
and we call technically the name for
this is sybils
and the reason is a book that was
published in the
70s and created a lot of
a lot of noise in the general public and
the psycho psychotherapy circles uh
it's about sibyl which is the true story
of a woman possessed by 16 different
personalities that's why we call
them sybils
the only problem with the story
well two problems actually first
uh sible is not her true name
and second the story is not true
so uh
so
what you should remember really is that
sybils are fake and duplicate okay
and they're they're bad they're the
they're the key challenge to to
democratic metaphors not not the power
and the money of the alternatives but
but addressing this program that's the
key key scientific problem that that
needs to be addressed and this will in
some sense this will be the the anchor
of of uh my talk
okay so that's the introduction let's
see
uh and so we can actually
dive into the talk the talk
itself so we're going to talk about
foundations for democratic metaverse but
but even that is is an overreach
so there are
social political
legal foundations that need to be
addressed i will not address them i will
talk only about computational
foundations for democratic metaverse
which
is an important component but definitely
not the only component that needs to be
addressed
and second i will not try to
design a democratic metaphor stop down
from from scratch
but rather focus on a
problem with which
in
technical sense it could be simpler but
it's in other sense it's more
intellectually challenging and from a
scientific perspective more difficult
and that's to to design
to afford the grassroots formation of a
democratic metaphor so we want to build
the infrastructure
scientific conceptual mathematical and
eventually software that will enable the
democratic committee versus to emerge
democratically in a grassroots way
so that's the focus that's the true
topic of the talk
okay
so let's define what a democratic
metaverse there is
uh you had a question no okay
so let's define what a democratic
metaverse uh is
uh
to a first approximation all we need to
do is add the word egalitarian equality
okay so democratic metaverse is a
network of egalitarian digital
communities
and if we want to expand it a little bit
more
we can talk about members owned members
operated and members governed
uh egalitarian digital communities
and conceptually it's nice to to split
these into into two
broader categories uh
communities and democratic communities
and these are really two aspects of
equality autonomous
protects equality from without okay so
we protect the equality of the community
against outside intervention or or
forces that can hamper equality
and democracy
protects equality from within so it
shares power equally inside so these are
two aspects of
being a so i view autonomous and
democratic as two aspects
of being egalitarian which is the key
the key topic
okay and i should add that
uh all i'm going to talk about is uh
all the papers are available on the
archive if you search
my name and the papers i'm a co-author
with are all
are all on their arcade
but i'll quote i'll mention them as we
go
ah
okay
there's one word which we sort of
neglected which is grass roots so we
don't see here grassroots
so let's edit
and there are two ways to add to at this
point
one is to put it here it's a network of
grassroots egalitarian
digital communities
actually i'd like to put it in a
different place i'd like to put it here
so it's a grassroots network of
egalitarian digital communities because
we would like to build the foundations
that even the network itself the network
of the communities can emerge in a
grassroots fashion and i will talk
towards the end about what what is
needed to to enable
grassroots network formation
okay so that's that'll be our working
definition and really everything i'm
going to talk about
in the talk is about making this
what is the basic science computer
science that is needed
missing or needed or has been done
already partially
or at least proof of concept or initial
basic science
uh to enable them a democratic metaverse
thus defined
so let's start with the most pressing
question which is how can you achieve
democratic governance
especially since uh we already said that
our democratic our communities will be
infested with sybils
what what can we do
so if the sybils are more than 51 and we
use majoritarian decisions then we're
we're dead in the water i mean siblings
control us and and there's nothing that
the real people can do about that
but even if there is only a single sible
we're in trouble because if the
decisions are majoritarian then a single
sybil can change the vote from
yes to no or no to yes or
et cetera so even in a simple majority
iron decision making even a single sybil
can hamper democracy and make our
results not trustworthy
so what can be done
well some work has been done uh uh in
the context of social choice theory uh
by connector and others
uh which
primarily showed negative results uh
that
not not much can be done
and and pointed some some direction to
to the future to success
uh i'm going to talk about the different
direction which is not starting from
ordinary social choice theory but from a
variant of it which is called reality
aware social choice
and we will see reality emerge over and
over you know it's always good to be
aware of reality as a general rule and
it turns out that technically it also
helps
in this context
and especially in the context of the
democratic metaverse
as computer scientists we want to kind
of think about the close about the
computational system that can be
formally defined but the whole notion of
equality and democracy
or the notion of democracy which
requires equality is always
in tension between
between the computational world and the
real world because the only meaning of
equality is as it relates to real people
not to computational entities
so we'll always see this interplay
between
computation and reality
okay
so
reality aware social choice says there
is reality
it's status quo and it's always there
you cannot vote on something without
having reality as one of the
alternatives
and it turns out it has nice things you
can resolve it has nice properties but
specifically
it helps us with uh
with the
civil resilience and this should have
popped one by one so
uh
uh i'll i'll still talk about it one by
one
the animation was lost so
civil resilient reality where social
choice introduces two notions safety and
liveness which together form civil
resilience
and what does civil safety says civil
safety says that we the real people
if if we're not for a change to the
status quo the sybils cannot force it on
us okay so that's safety no matter what
the symbols want to do unless the real
people want to change the status quo it
will not change that's safety
okay one four they can vote against
doesn't matter only if there's a
majority of the real people who want to
change the status quo it will change
that's safety what is liveness liveness
says
that even if all the sybils are clinging
to the status quo
the real people can still change it
maybe they need more than simple
majority maybe in the extreme case they
need unanimity but they can still change
it even if all the symbols cling
with their
clause to the to the status quo so
that's safety and liveness and together
it's resilience and the result of the of
this paper with the shahaf and the
talmud
is that if the sybil penetration is
below a sigma which is less or equal to
one-third
then a super-majority decision
of uh one plus sigma over two is
is both safe and live
okay so that's the main technical result
so basically instead of majoritarian
decisions
that we do two things
first
we always vote against or for again we
always vote
on specifically on a change to reality
uh with one alternative or multiple
alternatives but reality is always there
and second to change reality we need a
super majority not a simple majority
and under these conditions that not too
many sybils and we use a sufficiently
large super majority we have safety and
liveness and we can also have a contour
servo which
uh and break under cycles uh if there
are multiple alternatives
and also we have immediate rule which is
important for parameter update because
we will see a digital community has many
parameters it needs to control
uh
one of them is this uh this sigma itself
but there are others so we need the
community if we want these parameters to
be controlled democratically we need the
community the community to be able to
update parameters and the standard way
to update them is
to vote on parameters is the median rule
and we have a civil resilient version of
of the median rule so
this is a complete package
of uh of civil resilient
uh social choice based on reality aware
social choice assuming that reality is
is there also the
parameter is always an update against
the current value of the parameter it's
not the voting fresh on the parameter
value but should we change the parameter
so in this sense it's reality work
so we have sort of
the beginning there are lots of
lots of more work to be done i will i
will not delve into it but
this is a first initial proof of concept
that the problem can be solved in
principle
and that's a civil resilience social
choice
but they're still
still nagging
udi can ask a question sure from the
void so when you say that it's uh
grassroots essentially if we translate
it to language let's say cryptographers
recognize you mean that we don't know
the a priority the number who the
participants are what their even their
number is is that correct yes we want
communities to grow in a grassroots
fashion
and i will uh
the next topic is is how to achieve that
but i'm just asking about the definition
it means that you don't know in advance
who the participants are is that correct
yes yeah okay yes
you don't know in advance but in a given
community it's whoever is in the
community
yes
okay so two nagging questions
uh one is who this it we said okay one
person one vote civil resilience we can
vote successfully eliminate the sybils
but who decides what we vote on and it's
really fundamental
uh question of of of equality and
democracy
uh who chooses their agenda
and we're so used to just saying okay
one person one vote you're fine
but what are we voting on who decides
typically it's back doors you know uh
back rooms corridors
uh discussions that that that
are not transparent and are not subject
to scrutiny and after this cooking
that's happening something is put to a
vote
in congress
in in in referendum in in in whatever so
the question is who decides what
uh what we vote upon
and uh we actually spent so it's a
fundamental question of equality and if
you really want an
egalitarian
uh democracy you must address this in a
in a fundamental way
so we spent quite a lot of time on on
this question i will just touch upon it
briefly because these are
fairly deep mathematical papers
uh with colleagues um
so i will just mention the first of all
that it is
that doing one person one vote is not
enough for equality you really need also
equality in deliberation proposing
and and uh
and end voting but the equality in
voting
equality and voting alone is definitely
not enough
and uh
so
uh one one paper that tries to address
this
uh
is
takes
the three important domains for digital
democracy which is elections and
budgeting and legislation which is
important for any democracy but if you
want to program them in a community then
these are topics that you must address
in a digital in a
a living digital community
democratically
and
it proposes
uh that
we
that
social choice as both proposing and
voting in a metric space so we embed
all
uh all these domains in metric spaces
and equate voting with proposing is
putting a point in the metric space so
when you put a point in the metric space
as a person as a participant you both
propose it and vote for it
and we showed
that you can aggregate these votes uh
and have uh uh
and have uh
uh ways to to see what is the
most supported the alternative in a
given metric space
but this does not address reality as i
said
uh and
and does not talk about the liberation
so so it does
offer a direction for unified approach
for digital democracy which integrates
voting and proposing and also
integrating elections and budgeting and
legislation within the same conceptual
framework which if you want to program
this you want if you want on chain
governance which
i may have time to talk at the end or
answer questions then you really want a
uniform
conceptual infrastructure for
programming all domains all decision
rules you know with the one kind of user
interface one conceptual framework one
piece of software
but it does not address the liberation
or updating the status quo and there is
oh sorry i i should have said that this
is with the lauren
bulltown from paris
and uh
and we have another paper with idiot
ilkin
and uh david grossi
uh and and nimron talmon
uh on uh
on how to take this approach and move it
one step further
to talk about really dynamic and
and living democracy
uh how to can you integrate the
liberation and uh coalition deliberative
coalition formation to change the status
quo within the metric space
okay so basically we take the previous
paper of equating voting with proposing
ed reality
and deliberation is defined finding
alternatives preferred over the status
quo by as many agents as possible
and we have dynamic grassroots coalition
formation and conditions that guarantee
the liberation to succeed
under certain properties of the metric
space and behavior of the agents so
that's
another fairly fundamental theoretical
paper again a proof of concept
that the vision
of a unified approach to democratic
decision making which is truly
democratic
in which both the people deliberate
propose and vote on all topics on all
subjects in a unified and egalitarian
way
so this is kind of a beginning of a
proof of principle proof of concept that
this can be done
okay so that's who decides what to vote
on and another important question is who
decide
on the decision rule for example the
super majority delta sigma who decides
what sigma
to use and who who how who decides to
change it on changing it
so
let's see
ah
so do you know the story about ghetto
and einstein and morgan stern who
entered the taxi
who knows nobody knows
okay i'll tell you briefly so it's not a
joke
it's a real story
it's actually uh gudel was about to uh
uh go to the judge uh to be admitted as
a u.s citizen
and he needed two witnesses that uh
to join him to going to the judge so he
asked einstein and morgenstern
they were all in the uh
princeton advanced institute of advanced
studies and to to go with him to the
judges witnesses and they agreed
and then they started discussing in the
taxi what's going on and gadot says look
i have this difficulty of swearing to
the u.s constitution because it has a
bug
so
they didn't want to hear about this they
told him don't dare to tell the judge
that the constitution has a bug
you will not become a u.s citizen
so they spend their right you know
trying to convince him
and uh
they were not sure if they were
successful
but actually the first thing that the
judge said
was germany was under an evil
dictatorship fortunately that's not
possible in army in america
and what god promptly responded was
on the contrary i know it can happen and
i can prove it
okay
and also the judge told him okay i don't
want to discuss it
so until today it's a big mystery what
is the bug that ghetto found in the u.s
constitution because he didn't tell
einstein didn't tell morgenstern didn't
tell the judge didn't tell anybody
nobody wanted to hear it
but there are some speculations given
what ghetto is that it's actually the
rule of amending the constitution which
is not protected against being amended
so theoretically
the rule the american constitution can
be undermined
if
there is a sufficient majority you know
states and people and all that
to uh rescind
the the part of the constitution that
talks about protecting it from being
amended
and then
it can be easily amended to dictatorship
or whatever you want
so that's the conjecture about the
ghettos
yeah those
bug in the american constitution but
that's just to say that constitutional
law is very complicated or
conceptually
as complicated as goodwill's theorem and
self-modifying code and uh and et cetera
et cetera
so
but we really want to address it because
if we want to talk about autonomous
communities they're not subject to any
external law that can resolve things
it's not like company with bylaws that
can always adhere to the state law or
federal law to resolve conflicts an
autonomous
autonomous digital community
is autonomous by definition
so it must have constitutional
governance
and if it has one safe constitutional
governance who decides on the first
constitution
what is the initial constitution that is
needed you know big big questions
so we
we tried to address some of them and
actually this is a title of paper i
really like
in the beginning there were n agents
and excuse me for a second
it's with ben abramovic
and uh
we try to ask you know
can we
somehow design a constitution from first
principles
and the inspiration was maze theorem
which starts from
very
basic axioms and says okay if you
believe these axioms
the only decision rule that you can use
is majority so majority is not a kind of
a whim of someone uh that majority is is
a logical conclusion
uh of certain axioms that anyone who
looks at them would say yes these are
good accents
so
we tried to do the same and came up with
a set of nice basic axons which i will
not repeat here due to lack of time but
it's on the archive as i said
and also published
so we found a set of axioms that
together
imply that the only initial constitution
you can use
is what's called the h rule
okay and
i believe some of you are familiar with
the h index okay it's
every every scientist has an h index
which is the maximum number of articles
it has the maximal age
articles it has which are cited at least
eight times
okay so that's a very nice and good
measure so the h rule is is similar
and h rule is the maximum age super
majority
which has eight super majority support
to change the status quo including the
constitution itself
okay
so
if there is unanimous support
for changing the constitution only
unanimously so if everybody agrees that
all decisions should be anonymous then
it's unanimity but it's enough that one
person doesn't agree for your anonymity
unanimity then you cannot use anonymity
because there's no unanimous support for
unanimity
if there are two thirds
uh
two-thirds support for decision by
two-thirds and that's the maximal h you
can find then the super-majority will be
two-thirds et cetera so it turns out the
the h rule is the only initial
constitution that is consistent with a
very uh
basic set of axioms and again this is
relates to reality it's changing the
existing reality the existing status quo
you need you need the uh
you need h1 so that's
we have sort of a rational way of
defining an initial constitution
so
still open how to make it a
constitutional amendment a civil
resilient that paper doesn't address it
and also the question of on-chain
governance is a huge huge question uh
those are familiar with cryptocurrencies
et cetera the question of on-chain
governance of cryptocurrencies
is a major
issue
with people claim to solve it and people
others say that it's not solved in
general
it's not solved and by the way one of
the reasons one of the
uh
consequences of lack of on-chain
governance is forking that people
disagree and there's no no way to decide
how to change if you want to change
something you cannot formally decide
decide on a change within the system so
cryptocurrencies fork and bitcoin is
fought several times ethereum works
several times etc
so on-chain governance is necessary and
everything i've described until now it
can be thought of as building the
foundational support to enable on-chain
governance
okay
so that's uh
that's part of it
and also uh uh forking uh it turns out
can be also folded under their umbrella
of social choice
and there is a nice paper
also with the
ben abramovitz
on uh on forking
and actually the rule is is the rule
there is quite similar to the h rule but
formed
uh formed uh slightly differently
if enough people prefer to fork provided
enough people fork then they fork
okay so that's the democratic decision
on forking you know it's not
a social kind of thing it's not fighting
and
slamming the door and leaving it's a
democratic process with a well-defined
decision rule and if enough given all
the alternatives and the deliberations
etcetera and coalition formation and all
this that happens before if
faced with alternatives
enough people prefer to fork provided
enough people fork a fork will happen
okay democratically
okay so that's kind of wrapping up
um the questions of constitutional
governance and civil resilient social
choice as i said these are just proof of
concept that the direction is feasible
there's huge huge amount of work
conceptually scientifically
mathematically and of course
computationally to realize we realize
all that but
just uh so we have a feel that this is
doable
okay so now that where the hard part is
behind us we can talk about the more
easy stuff
um
and uh
you know all this assumes that somehow
you know we can bound the amount of
sybils in the community
and facebook you know is not that
successful
and if
we have here money and power to the
people you know
being a member of the community
gives you power of control and also
maybe give you a remuneration because
the community is is productive and
wealthy then the pressure on
on siblings entering the community will
be you know that much larger so the
question is
what can we do
and
how can we have a grassroots community
grow
and still be egalitarian not letting
too many sybils in
and
this is a paper
with uripco
and
uh it's fairly deep graph theory well
not deep it's it uses graph theory in a
fundamental way
and
and the goal is to
allow a community to form and grow
indefinitely while maintaining the
bounded bounded civil penetration
given a trust graph
and what is a trust graph here is the
community
these are trust edges
and there could be trust between
community members and outside members so
the applicants really want to establish
a sufficient trust and once there is
sufficient trust from people within to
an applicant from without then the
applicant can join the community that's
the kind of general idea
so we have
agents and and
and trust among them and
community members and applicants
okay so what are the assumptions first
there is a trust graph with good
connectivity and we use conductance
uh
uh to do that
and the second that only corrupt agents
trust sybil so you can think about it as
a definition of a corrupt i'm willing to
give my trust to a sybil means i'm
corrupt otherwise i would know that he's
a sybil or maybe this is zebel i created
so typically a person would create a
sybil and grant it trust and this way
pull the sybil into the community
and also another assumption which is uh
a strong one but we need it
that honest agent
agents trust only honest agents more
than they trust corrupt agents so that
good people tend to flock together you
know
that's a strong assumption and uh but
but we need it
and uh
again this picture you see that there
are three kinds of
agents there are civil identities
they're corrupt which are real people so
they're genuine identities but they're
the people who support
uh whoever whoever trusts with the sybil
is trying to pull them in
so we call the corrupt and the sible
byzantine and the honest and corrupt
genuine and there is some overlap so you
can have a genuine byzantine
uh
agent
and that's the main theorem i will not
walk you through it just the english so
the english says that if we have a
community history of the growth of the
community
that the graph is bounded you know
it's not too thick and not too thin in
terms of the degree
bounded from above or below
and initially the community is good so
you have a
initial from in the grassroots phase you
know you have people you know and trust
and you didn't get didn't let sybils in
and the edges between honest and
byzantine are relatively scarce so
that's what i said before you trust
honest people don't trust uh corrupt
people too much
and you grow slowly you know not too
quickly
and the conductance is uh the
connectivity in the graph is is big
enough then under all these assumptions
we can have a bound on the civil
penetration
so there's a big honor on the community
to grow slowly to check for conductance
you know to make sure all these things
and to ensure that its members don't
give away trust
for free easily and under all these
assumptions we can grow a community with
a bound in civil penetration
okay so that's a nice mathematical
result but
how is it related to reality
and there are two
fundamental questions that this
mathematical
in this mathematical world did not have
an answer first is
what where do genuine identities come
from
uh especially if you want them
grassroots you know if we are trust a
u.s government or some government then
say okay give me your passport give me
your id and i will know that you're a
real person
uh you're a person with this uh
passport number et cetera
but in a grassroots fashion where do
generate genuine identities come from
and the second is what does trust me you
know what do we trust and what happens
when the trust is breached so these are
two fundamental questions
and there's a paper that tries to answer
them
and
it's not mathematically very deep but
for me even as i prepared the talk it's
the most
conceptually challenging uh
issue
because it's very confusing as computer
scientists we like to think about you
know the computational domain and say
okay within this domain these things
happen and but but here this is really
about the connection between the
computational domain and the real world
and it's it's quite confusing so i'll
try to to explain this connection
so tries to answer the paper tries to
answer two questions two questions where
do genuine personal identities come from
and what what kind of trust is in a
trust stage
okay
and uh
the first question is okay identity or
identifier just a keeper you know
and uh grassroots solution
uh
we immediately have to immediately think
about this notion of self-serving
identity there's a whole community or
movement about
uh working on this and they have a uh
standards meetings and all that and they
want to support self-serving lenders and
that it is controlled by people not by
organizations not by commercial
companies on by google not by facebook
not by government
so we are definitely in this realm
except that they don't care about
genuine identities you they say okay you
can create as many identities that you
want for any purpose which is fine but
that's not the question in democracy
so if you want to to a grassroots
solution it's definitely within this
domain
and
the
if you think about the judge you know
the judge just accepted the girl he said
at the end of this discussion you know
you hereby granted u.s citizenship okay
so that's a speech act that's acting by
talking
and uh actually i think the concept was
was here in berkeley i think cyril was
in berkeley if i remember correctly
um anyway so that's uh
uh that's the notion or i hereby
you know you
declare your husband and wife or or king
of england or whatever that's a speech
act
so uh
if it won't self-sovereign identity the
only way we can start is by a speech act
of a person declaring that an identifier
keeper is
their self their genuine identifier
there's no other solution there's no
other authority that we can rely on
okay
so so this is
a real world event it's not a
computational event
and an honest person
declares once
that certain uh identifier is their
genuine identifier and a corrupt person
also declares you know sybils that's the
difference between honest and corrupt
people
okay so that's
the general concept
and uh
i i should mention that sybil is a real
world property not a competition it's a
connection between the identifier and
real people out there in the real world
so here are some figures uh here's a
corrupt person declaring many
identifiers here's an honest person
declaring only one and there's a big
problem which i will i will skip because
uh i want to talk about other things but
what if i need to if someone
knows my password if i lost my password
i need to create another identity
identifier but if i create an identifier
i become corrupt so how can i create a
new identifier without becoming corrupt
we have a solution but i will not
talk about it
okay so that's the notion of genuine
identifier and what is trust
specifically what kind of trust do trust
edges express
and what happens when the trust is
breached
and we have a notion called mutual
surety
uh which is sort of what the edge means
an edge in a truss graph means it means
mutual surety it has two components
first the speech act
i trust that some relation happens
between a real person and an identifier
on the other end of the edge
and second i'm putting my money where my
mouth is
and here's the money and if my trust is
breached i'm willing to lose that money
okay so that's what the mutual surety is
so it has a speech at component and a
money component
and uh
the many there are several types of
trustable uh
i will skip them because
of lack of time but i'll just say that
each of them gives you more power
for example
if i trust that you are the rightful
owner of this genuine identifier
this there is a leap of faith there
because i trust you that you have not
previously declared another one i don't
know that but i must trust that you have
not done it and you have not cheated
and it turns out that this is sufficient
for civil resilient community
information with random civil detection
i haven't shown you the protocol it's in
the paper but you can do
if you have random civil detection with
some probability you can use this
trust this level of trust to achieve
civil resilient community growth
for the previous algorithm i showed you
you need even further
i trust you that you are honest and
honest is much stronger it's a huge leap
of faith because i trust you not to ever
declare another identifier generally not
in the past and not in the future
and that's the trust needed
for for the other paper i showed you
before about community uh formation
okay so we have an answer where do
general identifiers come from from the
person from within by declaring
what does trust mean
i trust you
i trust some relation between this
identifier and a real person and i put
my money on that
and it's grassroots in in the sense that
we we discussed
okay
so there are some limitations first of
all conductance is a global measure
and it doesn't tell people what to do if
they want to join a community they
cannot increase the conduction they form
specific edges so
really a local measure will be much
better but
i pressured my
graph people and and they couldn't find
yet a good a good answer to that but
that's
uh that's the limitation
and
simple determination it's a real real
property it's not we cannot solve it
algorithmically you know we can
have algorithmic proposals for who is a
sibling conjectures maybe a first level
of decisions but you definitely
definitely need a due process at the end
of which people real people judges or
jury declare if an identity is a sybil
or not
and for trustages mutual sureties we
need money
you put your money where your mouth is
but
is there a contradiction between needing
money and wanting it grassroots what if
the people who want to form a community
have no money you know they're
poor people you know in world
today
the the penetration of smartphones is
much higher than the penetration of food
i mean there are many places around the
world where people are starving to death
and they have smartphones but they have
no food
so we should assume that that that
grassroots really means you know in the
broad global sense grassroots and they
have no money
so how can we
how can we have a grassroots
uh
formation if we need money
well the answer is here it must be
grassroots money we'll talk about that
okay so all this detour was to show that
we have a way to form communities which
is grassroots and egalitarian assuming
grassroots money assuming
okay
where are
we ah
so we started a bit late
i will uh i'll grab a few grab some time
from the questions for
uh and go on and uh
uh
where do you want when do you want me to
stop
no no it's good i mean we started like i
think at least five minutes late
so
so you have how about five more minutes
five more minutes okay any questions
okay
so i'll do my best in the next few
minutes
seven minutes
uh
so
democratic we know about democratic we
know about grassroots let's talk a
little bit about autonomous and members
operated
so
for if we want autonomous members
operated there can be no third-party
blockchains no third-party servers nor
third-party cloud computing should be
serverless which practically means
smartphone-based
protocol stack so i'll talk one minute
about smartphone based and one minute
about protocol stuff
so smartphones
nobody wants serverless protocols
okay nobody it's in against the interest
of any company on earth that we have
serverless protocols that's why we don't
have them
but it is in the interest of eight
billion people that we have serverless
protocols
that's why we should build them
okay
and uh
okay can this be done
first of all about the smartphones and
second conceptually okay so smartphones
i have beautiful photos i want to show
you very quickly
uh this is the z skin building
our shafi has an office
and also myself
and in 1949 it was actually the white
swan institute
it says here white's money in the city
of science is the only only building it
says that because this was the weizmann
institute of science in 1949 this
building now it's the faculty of
computer science and mathematics
and that's white sock it's
was at the basement of the weissman
institute at the of this building
and it was built in 1956
so that's part of it
it's another part of it
another part of it
there's another part of it
exactly occupied the entire basement of
that building
and it was very powerful computer
it's hard to get
accurate numbers but you know it's a
good approximate it's a it's a
um
generous approximation it could do
between ten and thousand k operations
per second and had between 64 and 256k
okay so everybody wants us to believe
that smartphones are not powerful enough
to do what we need that we need their
servers and cloud computing and all that
but
we can
and the second question which i'll spend
ten seconds on is
uh can we do a a
serverless protocol stack
and the answer is yes i believe still a
visual
but the point is that in such a stack
every application can be served best by
the simplest possible one so
peer-to-peer messaging
what's up facebook messenger we don't
need their servers we can do
peer-to-peer
and even uh personal currencies we can
do without
uh without uh
without ordering which is the full
blockchain protocol but if we need
ordering we can do the full blockchain
protocol it must be a dag
because it's a distributed partially
ordered
causality
if it's an open network
and i'll skip that slide
okay so i claimed without proof
that it could be smartphone based and we
can have serverless protocol
and the last thing is about members
owned
so again i will uh
just say
that it is possible
you know all the world wants this other
type of money but eight billion people
want this kind of money you know the
rich people want the other one the eight
billion people want this money which is
egalitarian and just and we have some
preliminary works on that
um
so
basically we can have egalitarian coin
meeting not by minors but by the people
and that results in just distribution of
wealth it's grassroots and civil
resilient
and it gives a sort of universal basic
income
so that's a paper by shahaf and uh and
almond and myself
and
i'll skip that
and
uh yeah this is just good things the
main theorem in the paper is that joint
egalitarian minting which means that
everybody means one coin every time
stamp even if he's a member of several
currency communities but the person can
choose which community to mint at every
time step
results in in
global distributive justice and
if there's enough intersection between
the communities there is also one-to-one
uh exchange rate between the different
currencies so it's a workable solution
it's the first step
i don't think it's the end of the game i
think the end of the game is actually
personal currency network which is not
published this is something
in progress but there are previous work
on this the goel it all has work on
credit networks
and there is a trustline's currency on
community currency which has this
similar ideas
so again this is work in progress but i
believe that
the end game of this in terms of
grassroots currency is actually personal
currency not even community currency and
i think it's workable
so
you have to believe me that grassroots
currency is conceptually possible and
desirable whether it's community or
personal
but still
we have results in community currency
others have proposals for personal
currency
and uh and i believe this is workable
and uh the last thing is about digital
communities i will
not talk about that
uh i'll just say
that uh
this stands on the on the basic concept
of of uh social contracts so digital
communities should be
viewed as
the digital incarnation of of the social
contract but not russo's about products
the honor the first anarchist
he was the is the first person who's
called anarchist
so he said that social contract is a
voluntary agreement among people and
we're talking about voluntary
digital agreement among people
uh which is realized and and enforced by
executing the agreed upon code so it's a
reminiscent of smart contract
but it's executed by the people
themselves not by third party miners so
it's autonomous
by the people themselves
and
many applications that should be
designed this way
uh democratic distributed autonomous
organizations
social networks credit unions
with community currency cooperative
digital cooperatives association
movement political parties if this
infrastructure becomes common good
then democratic alternatives
based on it could be developed
and
network i will skip i will skip
so
i tried to cover all these topics
and
as i said the papers those i spoke about
and those i glanced over are in their
kiev
and i hope i've convinced you that
democratic metaverse is important it's
doable
and lots to be done at the basic
computer science level thank you very
about
much
open the door to questions in the
audience
uh other than that
anybody
can you look at the okay the q a i don't
have in front of me actually
christine
you heard it
okay here so there's a question here um
don't you think that moving to the
metaverse is a way to dehumanize us
even if some notion of democracy is
achievable i have the feeling that the
more we digitalize our life the more we
humanize our very own nature not to
mention the effects of the brain changes
and behaviors that come behind curtains
with all these technologies okay
this is uh
this is talking about the other type of
foundations
okay
uh social psychological political which
i didn't claim uh
to make any contributions but i had my
personal opinion
and my personal opinion is of course i
highly value
real world communities actually i live
in a small village called nataf
in israel which has 500 people in it
and most people know most people there
so it's a true community
and i highly value it
and still i think that
this community itself could benefit
from better democracy there's
incredible discussions on how to manage
democratically the community it's a
democratic community but
you know arguing about how to do it
doing it in person do we work like this
uh et cetera et cetera so i think this
community could benefit even from a
community currency where because a lot
of interior community people do
babysitting and and services to each
other so actually i think i hope there
will be a guinea pig
for this
so so that's my answer
this is kind of um similar it's not
necessarily computational foundations
but i was wondering what you think like
how are the
like environmental impacts of the
metaverse like how does this factor into
everything
my idea would be sort of like um
if we think about you know the energy
output of the things we want to do it's
huge and
let's stop here okay okay okay first of
all i did i i held myself back not to
talk about the energy use of
cryptocurrencies but i think this is an
environmental disaster in the making
and if there was a
rational world government government
they would have forbidden proof of work
period as of today okay
there are other alternatives which do
not consume
and so much energy and and and
i personally believe proof of work is a
crime against humanity that's it
and china by the way is the first
country to outlaw and i think others i
don't think other countries should
follow suit on china in other topics but
on this one i think that's that's that's
the right one so that's that's the yeah
and when i when i speak about
you know smartphone based
that's one of the things you know it
will be green by by design
okay so that's that's the environmental
impact
second i didn't speak much about ubi
but
universal basic income but i think this
if this is successful
this will be the most powerful
approach to universal basic income and
for reducing inequality let me give you
some examples
um the main difficulty today with with
philanthropy
is is direct philanthropy if you want so
much money is lost on the way on the
pipeline from the time it leaves the the
the pocket of the philanthropy until it
reaches the final
many many people take their cuts
along the way
but
with such a system with genuine
identifiers that can be verifiable with
communities that trust each other you
could donate individually directly to
the needed people and don't tell me they
don't have smartphones because they have
and maybe there's one per family or even
one per village and it will work okay so
it's the most efficient way
and if we think about personal currency
uh it can be even more efficient
than than giving because
let's say that there is this personal
currency community out there in africa
somewhere you know and the rockefeller
foundation wants
uh wants to help them
they can say okay i'm gonna buy
one coin from each person every day for
one dollar
now we don't know what's going to happen
you know it could be that the price of
this currency will go if the price of
the currency will go above one dollar
the rockefeller to make due on their
commitment they don't even have to spend
money if the price is half a dollar
they still buy it but they buy something
that's worth half a dollar for one
dollar
okay
and if someone dumps their their money
in the open market and it goes to two
cents
then rockefeller can buy it for two
cents
uh
so so the commitment
to buy one dollar from every person in a
in a needed community
can give them can boost them directly
into a working economy a grassroots
economy with minimal outside
intervention and actually with very
little expense so that's an example of
what what what this will enable
okay uh of outside support
through a
uh
currency in egalitarian currency
community
with very little uh
outlay
question uh from the audience from
what guarantees do you have that the
democratic metaverse cannot be corrupted
by the real universe
okay
first of all hi moshe
uh
second uh
i have no guarantees as i said
the most difficult part
is
conceptually and and in all these
discussions is interplay between the
real world and the computational world
and
cryptocurrencies ignore it by saying
okay we don't care about the real world
you know
everything has happened happening
computationally and if someone can
fabricate you know uh
uh
a random number easily you know it's
there
good for them you know we don't know how
they got this number but here we say no
we want real people and and and real
trust and et cetera et cetera so it's
it's a difficult uh
there are no guarantees i think the best
guarantee is the grassroots nation in
nature so there's
there's no this monolithic metaverse
which will someday collapse
all these different grassroots
communities which emerge and maybe
federate
and and and grow together and they all
have guarantees and if some community
fails and because it was infested with
civils and others will disconnect from
it and then the damage will be contained
so so i think the grass roots
is the answer to to to this uh question
the next question is by daniel but there
are many daniels i don't know which one
and it has a lot of acronyms which i
hope you understand
what is the existing dao designs the
closest to achieving or adhering to
these principles is there any sop
a work that compares dao designs okay
dio is a distributed autonomous
organization and actually the first time
i saw
uh uh nothing against these activities
i didn't even know what dei means
director of these okay
uh
so distributed autonomous organization
when the first time i saw
the ethereum the
150 lines of solidity code describing
the first the first or simple
dao for ethereum i was
amazed i said i had a revelation i said
this is unbelievable
and and actually the the beginning of
this project said okay let's build
something on top of ethereum
okay and
computationally it's possible
but it will not be autonomous it will
not be egalitarian will this community
they will have to keep paying
you know ominous gas prices for the for
the third parties for the miners and
will be under their control
so
computationally
uh
from a computational point of view a dao
can be programmed
once we solve all these issues and how
can theoretically be programmed to
address them but if it runs on top of
ethereum we've done nothing
we've just
fed the beast with more
with more dollars and and until they
switch to proof of stake
uh we also cause more and more more and
more environmental uh damage
thank you for a very interesting and uh
thorough talk um i was wondering if i
could
uh hear your thoughts about maybe maybe
you skipped over it or maybe i missed it
so this this
idea of verification and simple
elimination
what will that do to the
i think very attractive and essential
ideas of anonymity and pseudonymity in
in virtual or non-virtual is that just
going to be a thing of the past now or
is that unifiable with this idea of
civil uh elimination because i think
that is still valuable even in
a democratic country thank you okay so
first of all
not every community has to be democratic
you know if you want to host a dungeon
for some sect that's going to do obscene
things in your dungeon
anonymously you can do it so i i'm not
claiming that the entire computational
world or the entire cyberspace has to be
democratic i say we must give a solution
for democracy and all the applications
are described uh especially the the
commercial one the kind of sharing
economy which really take money from
people to to defeat the lord
and not sharing
not sharing the wealth
uh all these definitely can benefit from
democracy but of course there will be
communities that people want
and even okay let's think about this
imaginary
situation where a group of terrorists
want to act democratically okay what
will they do
well maybe they will use them their
pseudonyms which each of each each of
the other
i see now the the bureau the french
espionage series i cannot stop seeing it
unfortunately uh
so um so let's say they did these uh
terrorists you know they they use
pseudonyms that each uh each knows
what the others they can still act
democratically they know who
what sidonim is the genuine identifier
of that person within this context and
still act democratically so we can have
we can have terrorist anonymous
democratic groups or
oppressed minorities you know whatever
oppressed minority is
as long as they use
pseudonyms that they know
and trust from each other
the next question is from carlos akin he
says what are the possibilities to avoid
civils all together perhaps
so carlo asks what are the possibilities
to avoid all symbols altogether perhaps
by a worldwide personal identifier code
which is needed to post something to the
metaverse yeah
okay that was sort of the hope of many
he said okay we'll just use the irises
or just use fingerprints or just use
some dna or something but you know there
are so many problems associated with it
of privacy
and
security and there is no way for this to
emerge in a grassroots fashion
so if there was a world government
and the world government would decide
that everyone will get
their id based on their left iris
from now and forever it will work but we
first need this world government and how
who will decide on it who will vote on
it you know how will we know that they
voted democratically or not that's a big
question so if we want grassroots we
cannot go this this way next question is
what if instead this is very falconday
what if instead of money surely we
institute a temporary ban
[Music]
uh on the trusting person as a penalty
after all membership in the community is
a valuable resource
yeah
okay there are many
there are many ways to to to uh
to do mechanism design you know as long
as there's something that's valuable it
could be money could be trophies could
be
uh you know suites
whatever it is uh it could work
but we need money for other reasons uh
and
and i think
my personal belief is that this would i
i'm still i'm still a minority in my
research circle
but uh my personal belief is that this
will the process will converge at
personal currency you know that's the
end point the end game is a personal
currency everyone will have their own
currency and we will use this to
negotiate and form communities and
community currencies etc etc
uh so that's
my personal belief that this is the
you know you need your identity and your
currency and that's
these are the
weapons you go or the tools with which
you go to the digital world so in fact
the next question was about speak more
about personal currencies but maybe we
should skip to there's a whole bunch of
questions which i'm also curious about
how do you get rid of symbols say it
again how do you get rid of sybils
how do i personally or
what is your proposing uh
i mean you have a lot of
yeah how do you get rid of civilians
well uh
again i
we we've shown that mathematically a
community can behave
okay you cannot get first of all you
cannot get rid of civil good
you cannot you can only create safe
spaces or safe communities
which prevent siblings from joining they
will be out there you know zillions
gazillions of siblings out in the world
in the in the wild but not in your
protected community
so what i described is how a community
can form
uh and
protect uh itself from sybil's entering
it that's that's the best that you can
do
there's another question here about
personal uh coins what happens at time
of death you know yes
that's that's uh
uh
actually a key question a key question
it's it's a fundamental question
because really a personal coin
uh again this is work in progress so i
don't have
uh but but the work in progress has
treatment of that
and and
um
a person a personal coin is really
credit that other people give you
and uh at the time of death if
you have uh
more credit than than assets then those
who gave you credit clues
and if you're a productive person and
have more assets and credits
then at the time of death or before just
before death all your
all your all the credits that's out
there can be redeemed against assets
that you have and those who trusted you
are
uh you know not in the red so but that's
definitely it's a fundamental question
of personal currency
what happens in death what happens in in
if you're insolvent
and these are
the work in progress which has not been
published yet is addressing this
uh maybe we uh we have seven more
minutes right okay another question is
um
to what extent uh do you think it's
important for the metaverse to maintain
a connection to real places in addition
to real people
movements like bio regionism and
rejournalism
and transition towns stress the
importance of defining computers in
connection to place and material ecology
do you think incorporating a connection
to a place is worthwhile extension of
your theory of a democratic metabolism
okay so
again personally personally i'm a great
believer in in community community life
and community life in the real world and
uh ideally any if this works and any
community in the real world could have
the tools to interact also in in the
digital world as a supplement or the
complementary
so i definitely believe in that
and communities are autonomous so they
can decide that this community is only
for the people of nataf and those who
are not in ataf cannot join or
those are you know all uh
you know
uh
some group of people the sports fan in
the jerusalem area and only sports fan
can join from the jerusalem area not
from other areas
so so definitely the community can and i
believe they would they are
uh
sovereign to decide who wants to join
i think the question was whether that's
a necessary ingredient or whether that's
going to be an enhancing ingredient
that's an enhanced ingredient actually
one in in the early days you know as a
lingering effect of of my
my startup days i i had a patent
on uh
on
establishing communities based on their
proximity
and
i forget what was the reason but we
ended up
uh dropping it
and it's one of my most cited
obligations because all the
other patents that are doing this
must cite this abandoned patent so
you know anyway so it's pr it's very
important
okay uh there's a question here is uh
how much of the democracy that you
propose
is explained by the term self-sovereign
examples are self-sovereign identity
self-sovereign date and so data and so
forth
well uh i have not invented this term uh
but i like it
and and i think
that
the community that's working on
self-serving identity is doing the right
thing in the general sense but they're
also struggling with governance you know
and how would you govern democratically
so they also
looking but don't have solutions yet to
this notion of genuine identities
so i believe
self-server and generated identities is
fundamental and that's how i described
it
i also believe that self-sovereign
personal currency is also important but
as of today i'm in a minority in the
in the in the team that that i work with
on currencies i speak with other people
and they think well
you know so i'm i i i believe this is
also important
but uh
but also the the
a key thing is the community you know a
community is also sovereign
in the sense that the will of the group
is to decide democratically what what to
do
there are two there are questions here
that are i think two of them are related
to each other so one of them is by dolby
tan he's asking why not solve it using
the democratic real world infrastructure
as they exist today
i have the countries where these
companies operate facebook youtube etc
force the companies to behave
democratically share their profits
voting etc if the promised civils have
each person declared to his government
their facebook details
and facebook will only keep those
accounts verified by governments
so the question here is why not use the
existing structure to solve the problems
you're presenting okay uh when i started
thinking about this you know several
years ago i actually wrote an article
about
how uh
how all these uh
digital uh
infrastructures that are emerging should
be viewed as a common good and should be
treated by governments as such
um i think i'm
still a very small minority on in
thinking but as i said this is
definitely the right direction
of governments defending democracy
within within each country but
this is not
based on what i
on the international
nature of the digital digital metaverse
and the fact that we don't want to give
any particular government you know veto
power on top of that i think that these
are complementary
approaches i think everything that's
proposed is good
but it's not enough and it's not instead
of a grassroots formation of of uh
democratic metaphors okay so there's two
more questions here
today's world is not fully digitalized
and governed birth registration is less
than 50 in many african countries
uh roughly 20 world population
which is yeah will uh the metaverse
[Music]
concept presented today work only in
tier one countries
so countries where there is birth
registration
well
again that's a big question uh
first i would say that whatever happens
with the democratic metaverse it will be
much better
than an autocratic or [ __ ] or
plutocratic metaphors and like the the
nightmare scenario was for india you
know that
that facebook will be the internet of
india
you know that was on the table at some
point
uh and rejected fortunately
so i agree that
global reach of uh
of connectivity and smartphones is is a
challenge but first of all all these
satellites satellite systems are uh
are emerging that will allow worldwide
connectivity and as i said unfortunately
uh and it's a very sad fact i think the
penetration of smartphones today in the
world is is
higher than the penetration of food
and um
and that's why this infrastructure could
help
practically uh you know transfer wealth
from rich nations to to poor populations
using this kind of uh this kind of
infrastructure
and this technology can be made to work
even if there is you know one person in
the family or one person in the village
with a smartphone there are technology
solutions to address that as well
great so now last
question following up on the identifiers
question are there not good ways to
design digital democ democratic
institution based on full anonymity
like for instance wikipedia
okay the
the two separate questions one is are
the people that are part of the
community real people
and the second is can their votes
can the anonymity of their votes be
protected and these are separate
questions and i think
of course the democratic community has
no choice but verifying that their
people are real
and of course the democratic community
that wants their votes to uh to be uh
not tampered with and not influenced by
should find ways to have the voting
anonymous and fortunately there's many
smart people who work on anonymous
voting the technologies are are still in
development there's no off-the-shelf
solution that guarantees that each has
its problems etc but
i believe that
that uh since they all
the the solutions that
that work are based on trust so you need
some people that you trust
so if a community has some people that
they trust
there's the shufflers that this and then
the community can inside it ensure
anonymity of votes
so that the people that they trust
actually do the
the anonymous voting protocol and at the
end they have the results which can be
verified without sacrificing
uh privacy
uh but this
any solution that that we come up with
must not be a third party outside kind
of contractor it should be within the
community
and i believe that the canola the
approaches that are being developed
today
can
can be realized within the community
that at least there are some trustworthy
people inside
so uh we're out of time but i'm going to
ask a question yesterday i was in an
interesting talk
where someone was talking about
[Music]
these fantastic
hci ways to interact for musicians to
make better music more interesting music
and it turned out that this advancing
technology
uh essentially introduced a disability
in people that are not uh which are
which can't see blind musicians because
you know some people are making much
better
music using interactions these guys can
actually not see the panels not use
those tools so of course the solution is
to make them also friendly to people who
can't see but it was an interesting
phrasing that technology sometimes and i
never thought about it
can introduce a disability just in terms
of sort of what is considered normal
so
how does this relate to your talk you
know there is this world okay where
people
um
are used to
and there's a lot of people i think that
are not technologically enough savvy or
part of the
you know the elite uh
world or young enough uh if such a thing
took over what any thoughts about what
would happen to
those left behind
uh
yeah it's it's a big question
and i mean taking a bus in tel aviv now
if you don't have
you don't know how to get the right
credit card it's very hard yes yeah it's
not even a credit card it's this
automated payment i know i i know
uh
i'm not pushing
democratic metaverse as soon as possible
tomorrow
i'm saying given the alternatives we
should fight that whatever comes up will
be democratic rather than plutocratic or
uh or autocratic yeah it's not your
issue it's all of ours yeah so
i think
but i think
there is a huge penetration of
smartphone technology and of course
satellite connectivity
and it could be put to a lot of good
uh and even if only the young people
have smartphones in the village you know
and can can know how to interact fine
they will help the elderly you know so
so i think
uh
we should work with what what there is
and and of course as i said i
i limit myself to the computational uh
part but they're huge questions uh
social political legal questions uh
um
and and and and the types that he raised
which of course should be thought about
and and addressed maybe we should
introduce a buddy system by eight anyway
thank you udi for a lovely discuss uh
talk and a very lively discussion i
don't know if you saw but we had almost
90 people on and you've given us a lot
to think about and thanks also for
coming in person and thank you
great to be here and to be with you
thank you very much
for all the real people all the real
people that are here
great